claude moniquet re bonsoir cette fois ci
on parle donc de la turquie cinq ans
après le coup d'état manqué à la chap
tayyip erdogan est souvent accusé
d'avoir mis au pas les institutions
turques qu'en est il exactement la
justice parce qu'elle est toujours
impartial avec près de 100 amis
fonctionnaires et un quart des
magistrats remercier je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire que la justice turque est
impartial la justice a souffert les
médias ont souffert la presse a été
fortement réprimée en fait d'après ce
qu'on comprend ce qui s'est passé dans
la nuit du 15 au 16 août au 7 juillet
pardon 2016
c'est une tentative de coup d arrêt elle
de militaires qui savaient qu'ils
étaient sur une liste noire qu'ils
avaient pour les plus regardées être
parlement arrêté parce qu'ils étaient
kémaliste ou parce qu'ils étaient
opposants à erdogan le coup d'état
échoué et erdogan qui était en conflit
ouvert depuis des années avec son ancien
mentor fethullah le dieu le dirigeant
fait la baleine a été en a profité pour
régler des comptes
donc on a eu des arrestations mais pas
parce par dizaines de milliers il ne
s'est pas semaine aujourd'hui cinq ans
plus tard et se passe pas une semaine et
parfois pas un jour sans que la presse
turque annonce qu'on arrêtait 10 15 25
baptisant du faite aux communes 10 pour
désigner l'organisation qu'il persécute
essentiellement mais aussi des
démocrates et des journalistes des
avocats des juges des militaires des
policiers
donc c'est vraiment une une manière
rebours pour eux erdogan de peut-être
pas d'un système de dictature j'aurais
pas jusque là mais de renforcer le
pouvoir qui est d'autant plus
autoritaire ça c'est très clair
et quelle est la popularité en turquie
pour accepter huberdeau annonce
évidemment des élections
ils 23h doan qui se montre actif sur la
scène extérieure le dossier libyen la
syrie avec l'opération rameau d'olivier
on s'en souvient la méditerranée
orientale avec la recherche
d'hydrocarbures en
en opposition avec la grèce et chypre
est ce qu a pas une volonté là de
diversion de la part d'air doan
en agissant beaucoup sur la scène
diplomatique à l'international pour
faire oublier peut-être sa baisse de
popularité à l'intérieur oui je pense je
pense que cet exode ont fait qu'il ya
deux aspects à la popularité d'erdogan
son statut dans l'opinion publique
d'abord il ya deux turquie il ya une
turquie il traîne mon moderne qui est
attiré par la laïcité qui rêve être
kémaliste fondamentalement qu'on trouve
dans les grandes villes entre autres
essentiellement à istanbul mais pas
seulement
et puis elle turquie rural patriarcale
beaucoup plus conservatrice qui est le
terreau de deux d'erdogan qui est
vraiment son électorat mais globalement
l'ensemble des turcs sont aussi liés par
un sentiment national très fort qui est
qui qui touche au nationalisme donc très
clairement quand comme quand erdogan se
pose en espèces de nouveau sultan prêt à
défier les américains prêts à défier
l'europe la france on se rappelle des
incidents qui a eu dans quelques îles
qui a eu en mer entre des vaisseaux des
vestes sûrs qu'ils ont osé vaisseau
français quand il tente de mettre la
main sur les gisements pétroliers ou
gaziers au large de la grèce tout ça
évidemment flax le pignon nationaliste
et l'ensemble de 2,9 ces deux facteurs
le nassérisme d'un côté et le facteur de
l'électorat conservateur religieux ultra
religieux qui soutient d'organes le cir
malgré tout une popularité réelle et
qu'elle s'en doute majoritaire en
turquie l'opposition c'est de plus en
plus les intellectuels les libéraux les
gens qui qui sont éduqués qui ont fait
des études supérieures et qui élit temps
de vivre de manière je dirais entre
guillemets occidental merci claude
moniquet d'avoir répondu à nos questions
rappelle que vous êtes expert en contre
terrorisme cofondateur du centre
européen pour le renseignement
stratégique et la sécurité